welcome back to Ye Olde David Pacman
show I am Jesse dollar Moore sitting in
for David while he is out vanquishing
dum-dums on their podcasts
talk about is the 2024 campaign for
Republican for the nominee for the
Republican
um who's going to be the candidate
and uh it seems to have been really
supercharged this week with his Trump's
trips to to New Hampshire and South
Carolina but there's also been kind of a
tip for Tat with with Donald Trump and
the presumed main opponent that he'll
face Ron DeSantis and
we're going to give a little history
lesson here and then we're going to play
some Modern stuff but I want you we're
going to go current and then back in
time and then back to current
because just the other day on his on his
what they like to call Air Force One
even though it's just his personal plane
Donald Trump was asking questions
answering questions about Ron DeSantis
and Nikki Haley the former governor of
South Carolina his former U.N Ambassador
about their possible run for president
and he he labeled Ron DeSantis disloyal
and he said well I talked to her about
it I told her to follow her heart but
she said she'd never run against her
president Donald Trump
and he also got this jab in on Ron
DeSantis about his mishandling of kovid
and his when he closed all the beaches
really taking a shot at DeSantis and I
want to remind you of that and then
we'll go back in time a little bit watch
this
Nikki Haley called me the other day to
talk to me and talk to her for a little
while but I said look you know go buy
your heart if you want to run she's
publicly stated I would never run
against
my president he was a great president
Florida was actually closed for a great
moment I remember we close to beaches
and everything else you know they're
trying to rewrite histories
it is
it is fantastic listening to Donald
Trump whine about Ron DeSantis trying to
re-write history
these Republican politicians exist in a
in a in an alternate universe where
video cannot be summoned by the internet
and watched again here's Donald Trump
from just uh just a handful of years ago
during the coven crisis being asked by a
reporter about Ron DeSantis and his
performance during the pandemic the
height of the pandemic and he is just
checking off just a A plus a plus report
card for Ron DeSantis so the guy who
he's now criticizing for how he handled
covid just just months ago really was
had nothing but praise for the guy
as many schools and school districts are
closing across a country Florida
Governor Rhonda Sanchez
sent out schools in May
um saying that many kids are not
vulnerable to this disease do you agree
with that assessment and do you believe
that schools would you recommend that
schools open up and to those states that
have well I have a lot of confidence in
Ron DeSantis a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis to make the right decision he's
doing a great job as Governor Ron
DeSantis I had read where he's thinking
about opening up the schools earlier
than the date the end of the month uh
I'd have to look at the numbers it's got
a lot of confidence in Ron DeSantis
check mark got a lot of faith in Ron
DeSantis
check mark
doing uh doing a doing a great job Ron
DeSantis a plus brother
[Laughter]
well Rhonda Sands is obviously just the
other day was asked about this was asked
about the specific thing about Donald
Trump uh taking him to task and
criticizing him for kovid and Ron
DeSantis shot I'm actually a little
shocked about it his response because he
clapsed right back and he does it in a
real uh subtle underhanded dig at Donald
Trump about being a loser in his
election
watch this it really does open up the
the the possibilities for what the
Republican stage will look like uh
during the campaign check this out
a number of times in the past couple of
days on a number of different issues
[Music]
what I would just say is this
um I roll out of bed I have people
attacking me from all angles it's been
happening for many many years and if you
look at the good thing about it though
is like if you take a crisis situation
like covid you know the good thing about
it is when you're an elected executive
you have to make all kinds of decisions
you got to steer that ship and the good
thing is is that the people are able to
render a judgment on that whether they
re-elect you or not and I'm happy to say
you know in my case not only did we win
re-election we won with the highest
percentage of the vote that any
Republican governor candidate has in the
history of the state of Florida
foreign
by the largest raw vote margin over 1.5
million votes than any uh governor
candidate has ever had in Florida
history and in fact we almost doubled
the previous record which I think was
like 780 000 vote margin and so what I
would just say is uh that verdict has
been rendered by the people of the State
of Florida
that's a dig that is absolutely a dig I
mean we'll paraphrase here it's look bro
I won my re-election what'd the other
guy do that's what he's doing here now
listen I'm I'm one who doesn't believe
Ron DeSantis ha he's not ready for Prime
Time Ron DeSantis isn't ready to meet
Donald Trump on the stage I think he
will go the way of Lil Marco Rubio and
try his best to keep up with Donald
Trump but when the rubber hits the road
and when Ron DeSantis has to face the
many insults and the slings and the
arrows that will be delivered by Donald
Trump he's going to fold like a cheap
folding chair
he's not going to have what it takes
he's not as slick he's not as brutal he
is not he's not going to be able to
withstand what Donald Trump brings I
think that's the case for just about
every one of these Republicans you can't
play the nice guy after we've Fallen
this far after the cruelty has been
amped up and ramped up to the level that
it has you're not able to go back and be
a John Kasich you're not able to be a
Mitt Romney you can't even be a Chris
Christie for that matter and when a
republican nomination for the president
of the United States so we'll see what
takes place but it is nice to see that
Ron descent isn't just going to lay down
for Donald Trump that there is going to
be a fight because listen a fight among
them is good for us when when when these
fascists are are spending time wasting
time and energy battling one another
that is time not spent destroying the
country
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping